This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. To be human, to be alive, is to be vulnerable to sadness and suffering. For centuries, artists, writers, and thinkers have tried to capture what this feels like. The author William Styron once said, The great drizzle of horror induced by depression takes on the quality of physical pain. But it is not an immediately identifiable pain, like that of a broken limb. It may be more accurate to say that despair comes to resemble the diabolical discomfort of being imprisoned in a fiercely overheated room.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。身为人类，活着，就意味着容易受到悲伤和痛苦的侵袭。几个世纪以来，艺术家、作家和思想家们一直试图捕捉这种感受。作家威廉·斯泰伦曾说：“抑郁症带来的那种巨大的恐怖细雨，带有一种身体疼痛的特质。”但它不像骨折那样，是一种能立即识别的疼痛。或许更准确地说，绝望就像是被关在一间极度闷热的房间里，那种令人痛苦不堪的折磨。
And because no breeze stirs this cauldron, because there is no escape from the smothering confinement, it is entirely natural that the victim begins to think ceaselessly of oblivion. Sometimes our suffering is connected to what we see in the world. During the Civil War, President Abraham Lincoln, who was already prone to depression, was often consumed by the horrors of the war. His secretary, John Hay, would note that he would sit for hours staring vacantly out the window, his face displaying the deepest sorrow imaginable.
由于这口“大锅”里没有一丝微风，由于这种令人窒息的禁锢无处可逃，受害者开始不断地想到遗忘，这是完全自然的。有时，我们的痛苦与我们在这个世界上所见到的事物有关。在内战期间，亚伯拉罕·林肯总统本就容易抑郁，他常常被战争的恐怖所吞噬。他的秘书约翰·海曾记录道，他会一连几个小时呆滞地望着窗外，脸上流露出难以想象的深切悲哀。
But as long as humans have been suffering, humans have also been trying to find paths out of suffering. Philosophers, scientists, and spiritual leaders have offered many ideas on how to live a life of contentment. Today on the show, we explore the ideas of an unusual philosopher king who lived some 19 centuries ago. There's a reason his meditations about a life worth living have survived nearly 2,000 years. Ancient ideas to help us find a way out of modern despondencies.
但只要人类还在受苦，人类也一直在寻找摆脱痛苦的途径。哲学家、科学家和精神领袖们为如何过上满足的生活提供了许多见解。今天在节目中，我们将探讨一位生活在约19个世纪前、不同寻常的“哲学家国王”的思想。他关于“值得过的人生”的沉思录之所以能流传近两千年，是有原因的。这些古老的智慧，能帮助我们找到摆脱现代忧郁的方法。
This week on Hidden Brain. Ancient ideas to help us find a way out of modern despondencies. This week on Hidden Brain. Most of us have been there. Low points in our life when we look around and realize that something needs to change. What we do in these moments can spell the difference between a life of well-being or a life of despair. At the City College of New York, philosopher Massimo Piliucci has personal experience with such moments in his own life.
本周《隐藏的大脑》。古老的智慧，帮助我们找到摆脱现代忧郁的方法。本周《隐藏的大脑》。我们大多数人都经历过这种情况。在我们人生的低谷期，环顾四周，意识到有些事情必须改变。在这些时刻，我们的所作所为可能决定了我们是过上幸福的生活，还是陷入绝望。在纽约市立学院，哲学家马西莫·皮利乌奇对自己人生中的这些时刻有着亲身的体会。
Massimo Piliucci, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's a pleasure to be here. Thanks for having me. Massimo, your world fell apart when you turned 40. Where were you living at the time? I was in Knoxville, Tennessee, the buckle of the Bible belt, as they call it. And what was going on in your life? I had
马西莫·皮利乌奇，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里。谢谢邀请我。马西莫，你在40岁时，世界崩塌了。那时你住在哪里？我当时住在田纳西州的诺克斯维尔，也就是人们所说的“圣经带”的中心地带。那时你的生活发生了什么？我当时
started my academic career at the University of Tennessee. I had I was a biologist at the time, not a philosopher, and I was being treated very well by the university there. But at the same time there were a couple of things that were problematic. Number one, the local culture was difficult for me to live in. I was a professor of evolutionary biology. My students, some of them actually told me that I was probably gonna go to hell. So I was like, you know, that's challenging.
在田纳西大学开始了我的学术生涯。我当时是一名生物学家，而不是哲学家，大学对我非常好。但与此同时，有几件事很棘手。第一，当地的文化让我很难适应。我是一名进化生物学教授。我的学生中，有些人甚至告诉我，我可能会下地狱。所以我当时想，你知道，这很有挑战性。
But the more important bit was that I had a daughter from a previous relationship and she was living on the East Coast in Connecticut. So I always wanted to move back into that area and that is problematic for somebody who is a full professor with tenure because there are very few positions available, especially in the East Coast, because everybody wants to go there and typically universities hire junior faculty, not senior professionals. So that was a problem. So that was a problem. Massimo tried to address the situation by applying for jobs on the East Coast. As luck would have it, he landed a position with Stony Brook University on Long Island. But even as it seemed like a solution was at hand for one challenge, others cropped up.
但更重要的一点是，我与前任有一个女儿，她住在东海岸的康涅狄格州。所以我一直想搬回那个地区，但对于一个拥有终身教职的正教授来说，这很困难，因为那里的职位非常少，尤其是东海岸，因为每个人都想去那里，而且大学通常聘请的是初级教员，而不是资深专业人士。所以那是个问题。所以那是个问题。马西莫试图通过申请东海岸的工作来解决这个问题。幸运的是，他在长岛的石溪大学获得了一个职位。但即使一个挑战似乎有了解决方案，其他问题又接踵而至。
Massimo and his wife started having problems in their marriage. Instead of moving together to Long Island, they decided to get a divorce. And then Massimo's father, who lived thousands of miles away, was diagnosed with cancer. So my father had been hit by multiple types of cancer. He was a big smoker. So at that
马西莫和他的妻子开始出现婚姻问题。他们没有一起搬到长岛，而是决定离婚。接着，远在千里之外的马西莫的父亲被诊断出患有癌症。所以我的父亲患上了多种癌症。他是个老烟枪。所以在那
point, my mother, his ex-wife, made a comment. He said, which is Italian for the bad weeds never die. She meant it as a joke, but it was, you know. She meant it as a joke, but it was, you know. And then all of a sudden things took a turn for the worse and it killed him in a matter of weeks. In fact, it was so fast that I did not have the time to really do anything. You know, I was on my way, literally on my way to the airport to get on the plane to get to Rome and go see him. And my brother called me saying, you know, that just that. I literally broke down crying on the
个时候，我的母亲，也就是他的前妻，评论了一句。她说“Erba cattiva non muore mai”，这是意大利语，意思是“坏草永远不会死”。她是开玩笑说的，但你知道。她是开玩笑说的，但你知道。然后突然间情况急转直下，他在几周内就去世了。事实上，太快了，我根本没有时间真正做任何事情。你知道，我当时正在去机场的路上，真的已经在去机场的路上，准备登机去罗马看他。我哥哥打电话给我，说，你知道，就是那样。我真的在
highway. I had to pull over. So I was able to get to his funeral, but not, but not being there in the last few moments. So at this point, picture this, In a span of a few months I got hit with this news that apparently I'm gonna be divorced, my father dies and in the meantime of course I had accepted the position at Stony Brook which meant that I had a new job, I had to move across the country and I had to find a new house. Now any psychologist worth insult would tell you that one or two of those things is pretty stressful. Four or five of them simultaneously? That's a lot. So during this time of upheaval in your life, you found consolation and guidance in an unexpected
高速公路上崩溃大哭。我不得不把车停在路边。所以我赶上了他的葬礼，但没能在他生命的最后时刻陪伴在他身边。所以此时此刻，想象一下，在短短几个月内，我接连收到这些消息：我显然要离婚了，我父亲去世了，与此同时，我当然已经接受了石溪大学的职位，这意味着我有一份新工作，我必须搬到全国的另一端，还得找一栋新房子。现在，任何称职的心理学家都会告诉你，其中一两件事就已经压力很大了。四五件事同时发生？那真是太多了。所以，在你人生动荡的这段时期，你在一个意想不到的
source. It was a book you had encountered many years earlier in college, but rereading it this time, you felt like it was speaking directly to you. What was this book, Massimo? The book was The Meditations by Marcus Aurelius, which is a stoic book. And that's interesting in itself because the first time that I came across Marcus Aurelius I thought Stoics? Who wants to live a life like a Stoic? I mean aren't these the kind of people that go around with a stiff upper lip and suppressing emotions right? So kind of like Mr Spock from Star Trek. So when I came across Marcus again I thought hmm I don't know about this thing.
来源中找到了慰藉和指引。那是一本你在大学时就读过的书，但这次重读时，你觉得它仿佛在直接与你对话。马西莫，这是什么书？这本书是马可·奥勒留的《沉思录》，这是一本斯多葛派的书。这本身就很有趣，因为我第一次接触马可·奥勒留时，我想：斯多葛派？谁想过斯多葛派那样的生活？我的意思是，他们不就是那种整天板着脸、压抑情感的人吗？就像《星际迷航》里的斯波克先生。所以当我再次遇到马可时，我想：嗯，我不确定这个。
So when I came across Marcus again I thought hmm I don't know about this thing. And then I opened the meditations and one of the first phrases... so the meditation is not the kind of book that you necessarily read cover to cover because it is it was the personal philosophical diary or journal of the emperor so it was not in fact meant for publication. So when I opened it up at random one of the first few sentences opened it up at random, one of the first few sentences that I found is in one of the later books and it said something like, you don't like the cucumber because it's bitter. Well, don't eat it. Why do you have to go on and complain about the fact that there are bitter cucumbers in the world? That struck me as very powerful and very insightful.
所以当我再次遇到马可时，我想：嗯，我不确定这个。然后我打开了《沉思录》，其中最早的几句话之一……所以《沉思录》并不是那种你一定要从头读到尾的书，因为它是这位皇帝个人的哲学日记或笔记，所以它实际上并不是为了出版而写的。所以当我随意打开它时，我发现的最早的几句话之一，是在后面的篇章里，它大概是这样说的：你不喜欢黄瓜，因为它很苦。好吧，那就别吃它。你为什么要一直抱怨世界上有苦黄瓜呢？这让我觉得非常有力，也非常深刻。
We tend to complain all the time about the fact that things don't go our way, that the world is not the way we would like it to be. And those complaints don't do anything practical. They're not actionable. So complaining about it becomes simply a way to wallow in your self pity or to fuel your own dissatisfaction with the world, which makes the thing worse. So now you have both an external situation, some aspect of the world that you don't like, and you are making yourself inwardly worse by complaining about it in a way that it gets frustrating because you can't do anything about it. So I went back to that phrase it says okay there
我们总是倾向于抱怨事情不顺心，抱怨世界不是我们想要的样子。而这些抱怨没有任何实际作用。它们是不可操作的。所以抱怨它只会成为一种沉溺于自怜，或者助长你对世界不满的方式，这只会让事情变得更糟。所以现在你既有一个外部情况，即世界上你不喜欢的一面，又通过抱怨让自己内心变得更糟，这让人感到沮丧，因为你对此无能为力。所以我回到那句话，它说：好吧，
are bitter cucumbers in the world that's a fact right? I do not have the power to eliminate bitter cucumbers from the world. I do have the power to refuse to eat them and that's it. Marcus is absolutely right. I don't need the additional step of complaining and involving in this fact that the world is so unfair because there is bit of cue commerce. That was the beginning or one of the beginnings because I also got pretty much at the same time another stunning phrase from Epictetus, another stunning phrase from Epictetus, who was one of the inspirations to Marcus, so the two are very closely related. Epictetus was another interesting guy. You know, Marcus Aurelius was an emperor, so literally the most powerful person in the Mediterranean world at the time. Epictetus was at the opposite extreme. He was a slave. He started out life as a slave. He was actually
世界上有苦黄瓜，这是事实，对吧？我没有能力消除世界上的苦黄瓜。但我有权拒绝吃它们，就这样。马可说得完全正确。我不需要再多此一举去抱怨，去纠结于世界因为有苦黄瓜而如此不公的事实。那是开始，或者说是开始之一，因为我几乎在同一时间从爱比克泰德那里得到了另一句令人震惊的话，爱比克泰德是马可的灵感来源之一，所以两人关系非常密切。爱比克泰德是另一个有趣的人。你知道，马可·奥勒留是一位皇帝，所以他实际上是当时地中海世界最有权势的人。爱比克泰德则处于另一个极端。他是个奴隶。他以奴隶的身份开始生活。他实际上
eventually freed and he became actually one of the most well-known and respected teachers in the Mediterranean area at the beginning of the second century. So he had a completely different sort of life trajectory. And yet the ideas, the Stoic ideas, resonated a panther with both of these people and both of them became major conduits for later generations. And one of the things that Epictetus says at the beginning of the discourses is, so you wanna make money, he's talking to some of his friends, you wanna make money or you want me to make money
最终获得了自由，并成为了二世纪初地中海地区最著名、最受尊敬的老师之一。所以他的人生轨迹完全不同。然而，这些思想，这些斯多葛派的思想，在他们两人身上都产生了共鸣，他们两人都成为了后代的重要传播者。爱比克泰德在《语录》开头说的一件事是：你想赚钱，（他在和朋友交谈），你想赚钱，或者你想让我赚钱，
so that I can help you. Well, that's all fine. But what am I gonna do with that money? The money itself isn't gonna tell me. What's gonna tell me is my faculty of judgment. Epictetus uses this to make the general stoic point that so-called externals, things like money or health even or reputation, are not the fundamental thing. They're not crucial because it all depends on how you use them.
这样我就可以帮助你。好吧，这都没问题。但我拿这些钱做什么呢？钱本身不会告诉我。会告诉我的是我的判断力。爱比克泰德用这一点来阐述斯多葛派的一般观点，即所谓的“外部事物”，比如金钱、健康甚至名誉，并不是根本性的东西。它们并不关键，因为这一切都取决于你如何使用它们。
You can be very rich and do a lot of damage or you may be very poor and actually use your resources very wisely. To Epictetus and Marcus it's not fame or money or wealth or whatever it is per se, it's how you use them that makes a difference and that struck me as another fundamental insight from Stoicism that why are you now focusing on improving your decision-making ability? And you keep focusing instead on more or less mindlessly follow what society at large tells you. You're trying to become more wealthy, more famous and so on and so forth.
你可以非常有钱却造成很多破坏，或者你可能非常贫穷却非常明智地利用你的资源。对爱比克泰德和马可来说，名声、金钱、财富本身并不重要，重要的是你如何使用它们，这让我觉得这是斯多葛主义的另一个基本见解：为什么你现在不专注于提高自己的决策能力？而是一直专注于或多或少盲目地追随社会大众告诉你的东西。你试图变得更富有、更出名等等。
Hold on. What are you going to do with all that stuff once you have it? When we come back, how the ideas of Marcus Aurelius can help us steer a course through the challenges of modern life. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Massimo Pelliucci is a philosopher at the City College of New York. At a low point in his life, he rediscovered a 1900 year old set of personal reflections written by the Roman emperor, Marcus Aurelius. It is widely known today by the simplest of titles, meditations. Massimo, describe who Marcus Aurelius was and the kind of world in which he operated.
等等。一旦你拥有了所有这些东西，你打算用它们做什么？稍后回来，我们将探讨马可·奥勒留的思想如何帮助我们驾驭现代生活的挑战。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。马西莫·皮利乌奇是纽约市立学院的哲学家。在他人生低谷时，他重新发现了一套由罗马皇帝马可·奥勒留撰写的、拥有1900年历史的个人反思录。今天，它以最简单的书名广为人知：《沉思录》。马西莫，请描述一下马可·奥勒留是谁，以及他所处的那个世界。
So he was one of the so-called five good emperors. Marcus had a difficult time as an emperor. He did not want to be an emperor. He was really not that interested. In the meditations at some point he says, you can live a good life anywhere. If you have to be in a palace, then you can have a good life even in a palace,
他是所谓的“五贤帝”之一。马可作为皇帝度过了一段艰难的时期。他并不想当皇帝。他真的对此不太感兴趣。在《沉思录》的某个地方，他说：你可以在任何地方过上好生活。如果你必须住在宫殿里，那么即使在宫殿里你也能过上好生活，
which tells you that he wasn't exactly thrilled. And he did not have an easy reign, unlike the others, especially his predecessor Antoninus Pius. Because during Marcus' reign a number of things happened. Two frontier wars. There was an attack on the frontiers of the empire in the east by the Parthians and from the north from a number of German tribes, chiefly the Marcomanni.
这说明他并不怎么感到兴奋。而且他的统治并不轻松，不像其他人，尤其是他的前任安东尼·庇护。因为在马可统治期间，发生了很多事情。两场边境战争。帝国东部的边境受到了帕提亚人的攻击，北部也受到了许多日耳曼部落（主要是马科曼尼人）的攻击。
It had to deal with an internal rebellion by one of his lieutenants who declared himself emperor. Rome was hit by a devastating flood of the Tiber River that destroyed half of the city. A huge earthquake demolished the city of Smyrna in modern western Turkey and the emperor also had to deal with that. So he had his hands full. And what he did throughout was to do his best in order to apply his stoic philosophy to the situation. So here's a case where we literally have an emperor philosopher or a philosopher king as Plato would put it.
他不得不处理一名自立为帝的副官发起的内部叛乱。罗马遭遇了台伯河的毁灭性洪水，摧毁了半个城市。一场大地震摧毁了现代土耳其西部的士麦那城，皇帝也必须处理这些问题。所以他忙得不可开交。他所做的一切，就是尽其所能将他的斯多葛哲学应用到这些情况中。所以这是一个我们真正拥有“哲学家皇帝”或柏拉图所说的“哲学家国王”的案例。
We have somebody who is not only interested in philosophy for its own sake, but he actually is determined to use philosophy as a way of life and therefore as a framework to make decisions both personal and political. And that really did make a difference. Arguably, that's one of the things that made him a great emperor. ["The Great Emperor's Theme"] So, the Stoics basically talk about a regular part of life, which is a practice known as evening meditation.
我们拥有的人不仅对哲学本身感兴趣，而且他实际上决心将哲学作为一种生活方式，并以此作为制定个人和政治决策的框架。这确实产生了影响。可以说，这是让他成为伟大皇帝的原因之一。["伟大皇帝的主题"] 那么，斯多葛派基本上谈论的是生活中的一个常规部分，即一种被称为“晚间沉思”的练习。
What is this, Massimo? How is it conducted? You can think of the entire meditations as a series of evening meditations, but the exercise is also described briefly in Epictetus and at more length in Seneca. It basically consists in this. Before you go to bed you take a little bit of time, not a lot, five, ten minutes maybe, you get into a quiet corner both your house and your mind, and then you go and reflect on salient events that happened during the day, asking yourself how you reacted,
这是什么，马西莫？它是如何进行的？你可以把整部《沉思录》看作是一系列晚间沉思，但这种练习在爱比克泰德的著作中也有简要描述，在塞内卡的著作中则有更详细的描述。它基本上包括这一点。在你睡觉前，你花一点时间，不用太多，也许五到十分钟，让你家里的环境和你的内心都安静下来，然后去反思当天发生的重大事件，问问自己你是如何反应的，
how you handled those things. Seneca specifically, for instance, says, you know, you should go over and say, what have I learned today? How am I improved myself? In what way am I better? Epictetus is even more specific. It says that we need to ask ourselves three questions. What did I do wrong? What did I do right? And what could I do better the next time that something like that happens?
你是如何处理这些事情的。例如，塞内卡特别说，你应该回顾一下并说：我今天学到了什么？我如何改进了自己？我在哪些方面变得更好了？爱比克泰德更具体。他说我们需要问自己三个问题：我做错了什么？我做对了什么？下次发生类似事情时，我能做得更好吗？
It has very good empirical backing from modern science. It really does work. It is a kind of self-analysis. Now, there is a limitation in doing self analysis which is, especially modern psychologists have demonstrated, you know human beings are very good at rationalizing. So you can write down things and then you can you can make up all sorts of excuses about why you did certain things or you didn't do other things. But the stories were aware of that which is why they said well you need to do said, well, you need to do the self-analysis, you need to do the self-examination, but you also need some help. And there are two major sources of help for the Stoics.
它有来自现代科学的很好的实证支持。它确实有效。这是一种自我分析。现在，进行自我分析有一个局限性，那就是，正如现代心理学家所证明的那样，人类非常擅长合理化。所以你可以写下一些事情，然后你可以编造各种借口来解释为什么你做了某些事情，或者为什么你没有做其他事情。但斯多葛派意识到了这一点，这就是为什么他们说，好吧，你需要做自我分析，你需要做自我审视，但你也需要一些帮助。对于斯多葛派来说，有两个主要的帮助来源。
One is to imagine a role model. So imagine that you're actually talking to somebody. If you notice, the meditation is written in the second person. It's not, I did this, but you did this. As if Marcus were writing to a friend or to somebody else who was listening and he was giving advice to that person. Even though he was talking about himself.
一个是想象一个榜样。所以想象你实际上是在和某人交谈。如果你注意到，《沉思录》是用第二人称写的。它不是“我做了这个”，而是“你做了这个”。就好像马可是在写给朋友或正在倾听的某个人，他在给那个人建议。尽管他是在谈论自己。
Even though he was talking about himself. And again, that is very good. I was just reading an article the other day in psychological literature. There's pretty good evidence that this technique helps achieving an emotional detachment to some extent from your own actions and therefore engaging more analytically, more critically with what you've done. And the other external help is talking to a friend, literally talking to a friend.
尽管他是在谈论自己。再说一次，这非常好。我前几天刚在心理学文献中读到一篇文章。有相当好的证据表明，这种技巧有助于在一定程度上实现与自身行为的情感脱离，从而更具分析性、更批判性地参与你所做的事情。另一个外部帮助是与朋友交谈，真正地与朋友交谈。
And the Stoics thought that friends, real friends, are so-called friends of virtue. The kind of friends that are okay telling you that you're doing something wrong if they do think that you're doing something wrong. And you don't need a lot of them, but it's important to have at least one. To have that kind of person that you can go and have a drink and say, you know, I got this issue, what do you think? So I understand that these evening meditations have now become a regular part of your life, Massimo? Yeah, I've been doing it for years. Do you understand that these evening meditations have now become a regular part of your life, Massimo?
斯多葛派认为，朋友，真正的朋友，是所谓的“美德之友”。那种如果你确实做错了事，他们会愿意告诉你你做错了的朋友。你不需要很多这样的朋友，但至少有一个是很重要的。拥有那样一个人，你可以和他去喝一杯，说：“你知道，我有这个问题，你怎么看？”所以我了解到，这些晚间沉思现在已经成为你生活中的常规部分了，马西莫？是的，我已经坚持多年了。所以我了解到，这些晚间沉思现在已经成为你生活中的常规部分了，马西莫？
Yeah, I've been doing it for years. And if you know that there is a recurring issue, let's say anger, for instance, or frustration, or whatever it is, then you just say, okay, how was I doing five years ago with this? Or what kind of themes was I preoccupied with? What kind of issues were bothering me ten years ago as opposed to now? And so it becomes also a way to keep track of progress. Am I doing better on this thing? Is it something that 10 years ago was bothering me a lot and now it's not because I've actually made progress? And if not, then perhaps that's one thing that I need to focus on that I was not sufficiently aware of. So before you became a student of Marcus Aurelius
是的，我已经坚持多年了。如果你知道有一个反复出现的问题，比如愤怒，或者挫折，或者其他什么，那么你就说，好吧，五年前我在处理这个问题时做得怎么样？或者十年前我被什么样的主题所困扰？与现在相比，当时有什么问题在困扰我？所以这也成为了一种跟踪进步的方式。我在这个问题上做得更好吗？这是十年前困扰我很多，而现在不再困扰我的事情吗，因为我实际上取得了进步？如果不是，那么这可能就是我需要关注的一点，而我之前并没有充分意识到。所以，在你成为马可·奥勒留的信徒之前
and Stoic philosophy, Massimo, you wrestled with your feelings about a particular aspect of your physique. What was it that bothered you? I've always been a little bit overweight since I was a kid, and in fact, arguably still am. And so I struggled with that because, and initially I struggled with that
和斯多葛哲学的学生之前，马西莫，你曾纠结于对自己体型某个方面的感受。是什么困扰着你？我从小就有点超重，事实上，可以说现在依然如此。所以我为此挣扎，因为，起初我以一种不健康的方式挣扎，我会说，这很典型，因为你有来自同龄人的压力，甚至是我父母的压力。我在初中时，父母带我去看营养师，这可能反应过度了，因为问题肯定没有那么严重。
in an unhealthy way, I would say, which is kind of typical because you have pressure from your peers, even my own parents. My parents brought me to a dietician when I was in middle school or something like that, which probably was way of an overreaction because the problem certainly was not that dramatic.
但一旦你陷入，你知道，你观察到他人的观念，包括那些爱你的人，认为这是一个问题，这是一个问题，你真的需要努力解决它，那么它就很容易变成一种强迫症。因此不健康。所以我断断续续地为此挣扎，你知道，
But once you get into, you know, you observe the notion from others, including the people who love you, that there is an issue, that there is a problem, that you need really to work on it, then it becomes, it easily becomes an obsession. And therefore not healthy. So I struggle with that on and off, you know,
所以自我形象，有时这在人际关系方面给我带来了麻烦。我只是不知道如何处理，或者因为我的身体形象问题，不知道如何去追求一段友谊或一段关系。所以马可·奥勒留在这里有一些见解可以贡献。他说尊重
so self-image, sometimes it got me into trouble in terms of relationships. I just wouldn't know how to handle or wouldn't know how to pursue necessarily a friendship or a relationship because of my body image problem. So Marcus Aurelius has some insight to contribute here. He says that it's important to respect
他所谓的“控制二分法”很重要。马西莫，这个想法是什么？这是一个基本的斯多葛派思想。事实上，“控制二分法”这个短语是现代的。古人自己，爱比克泰德，他是马可·奥勒留的影响者，对马可的主要影响者之一，他称之为“基本规则”，这本身就告诉你，你知道，它很重要。所以基本规则说，有些事情取决于我们，
what he calls the dichotomy of control. What is this idea, Massimo? This is a fundamental stoic idea. In fact, the phrase dichotomy of control is actually modern. The ancients themselves, Epictetus, who was Marcus Aurelius' influence, one of the major influences on Marcus, he calls it the fundamental rule, which right there tells you, you know, it's important. So the fundamental rule says that some things are up to us
而另一些事情不取决于我们。然后它给你建议说，看，如果确实存在这种区别，你需要专注于取决于你的事情，因为那是你的能动性真正有效的地方。那是你可以有所作为的地方。你需要对那些
and other things are not up to us. And then it gives you the advice of, look, if there is in fact this distinction, you need to focus on the stuff that is up to you because that's where your agency is actually efficacious. That's where you can make a difference. And you need to develop a mindful, purposeful attitude of acceptance and equanimity toward
不取决于你的事情，培养一种正念的、有目的的接受和泰然处之的态度。这是一个在许多其他文化中都会出现的概念。它不仅仅是斯多葛派的。它出现在犹太教、古代犹太教、古代佛教、现代基督教中，例如《宁静祷文》，它是20世纪初的基督教祷文，用于像“戒酒互助会”这样的12步组织的会议中，本质上做的就是同样的事情。它在这种情况下祈求上帝给你智慧去弄清楚你能改变什么，不能改变什么，给你勇气去改变你能改变的，并给你确定性去接受你不能改变的。
the kinds of things that are not up to you. This is a notion that comes up in a number of other cultures. It's not just stoic. It comes out in Judaism, ancient Judaism, ancient Buddhism, modern Christianity, the Serenity Prayer, for instance, that it's an early 20th century Christian prayer used in meetings of 12-step organizations like Alcoholic Anonymous, essentially does the same thing. It asks God in this case to give you the wisdom to figure out what it is that you can change, what you cannot, the courage to change what you can, and the certainty to accept what you cannot.
现在，爱比克泰德和马可说，取决于我们的本质上是你的判断，你对情况的评估以及如何处理它。仅此而已。换句话说，你对世界的反应。你对世界的反应。不取决于我们的是几乎所有其他事情。这很反直觉，对吧？
Now, Epictetus and Marcus say that what is up to us are essentially your judgments, your assessment of a situation and how to deal with it. That's all. Your response to the world, in other words. Your response to the world. What is not up to us is pretty much everything else. Which is counterintuitive, right?
因为你会说，等一下。所以爱比克泰德和马可都列出了一系列不取决于我们的事情。他们从健康开始。所以他们说健康、财富、名誉、事业、人际关系等等。就像健康，你是什么意思，健康不取决于我？
Because you say, wait a minute. So Epitetus and Marcus both list a series of these things that are not up to us. And they start with health. So they say health, wealth, reputation, career, relationships and all that. It's like health, what do you mean health is not up to me?
当然，所以我们刚才在谈论我的身体形象问题，你是什么意思，我的健康不取决于我？当然。所以我们刚才在谈论我的身体形象问题。你是什么意思，我的健康不取决于我？当然取决于我。我可以为我的健康做各种各样的事情，对吧？我可以吃健康的饮食。你知道，我可以去锻炼。我可以定期去看医生并进行预防性医疗。
Of course, so now we were talking about my body image problems, what do you mean my health is not up to me? Of course. So now we were talking about my body image problems. What do you mean my health is not up to me? Of course it is. I can do all sorts of things about my health, right? I can eat a good diet. You know, I can go and exercise. I can go to the doctor on a regular basis and practice preventive medicine.
我的意思是，我可以做所有这些。但当你仔细思考时，你会说，啊，但等一下。那些都是判断，或者是采取行动或不采取行动的决定。我不控制的，不取决于我的是结果。当然，我可以吃得健康，我可以去健身房，我确实经常去，我也定期去看医生。
I mean, I can do all those. But then you think about it and say, ah, but wait a minute. Those are all judgments or decisions to act or not to act. What I don't control, what is not up to me is the outcomes. Sure, I can eat healthy, I can go to the gym, which I do, largely, and I go regularly to the doctor.
尽管如此，还有许多其他因素会影响结果，影响实际的健康，这些因素不在我的控制范围内。我可以尽我所能，但在某种程度上，我受到自身基因和早期成长环境的限制。我们知道，基因和早期发育，甚至出生前的宫内发育，
Nevertheless, there are a lot of other factors that contribute to the outcome, to the actual health that are not under my control. I can make all the efforts I want, but to some extent I am limited by my own genetics and my own early upbringing. We know that both the genetics and early development, even intrauterine development before you're born
当然还有发育的最初几个月，这些对于决定你长期对某些事情的反应至关重要。而我对这些毫无控制力。我不能重新排列我的基因。我没有选择我的基因，等等等等。所以总的观点就变成了，看，一方面，你从一开始就接受这样一个概念，即你对任何事情都没有完全的控制权，任何外部事物，这些事情都不在其中。
and certainly the first few months of development, those are crucial to determine, you know, how're going to respond long-term to certain things. And I had no control over those. I can't rearrange my jeans. I didn't pick my jeans and so on and so forth. So the general idea then becomes that, look, on the one hand, you accept from the get-go the notion that you do not have full control over anything, anything that is external, none of those things.
你需要对此感到坦然，因为你有什么选择？只有两个选择。你要么坦然接受，要么大发脾气。大发脾气没有帮助。这是孩子们做的事情，因为他们在情感上不成熟。成年人不应该做那种事情。
And you need to be okay with it because what are your choices? There's only two choices. You're either okay with it or you throw a tantrum. Throwing a tantrum doesn't help. It's the kind of thing that children do because they're not emotionally mature. An adult is not supposed to do that sort of stuff.
而且，大发脾气不仅没有帮助，反而会碍事，因为现在你是在外部伤害的基础上，又增加了一种内在的伤害。事实上，现在你因为失去了控制而感觉糟糕，你感到焦虑等等。所以你需要专注于你实际上能做的事情，这赋予了你力量，因为这个想法是，你实际上能做的事情，这赋予了你力量，
Also, throwing a tantrum not only doesn't help, but actually gets in the way, because now you're adding the actual injury from the external to an internal imposed injury. The fact that now you feel bad because you've lost control, you're anxious and so on and so forth. So you need to focus on what actually you can do, which is empowering, because the idea is what actually you can do, which is empowering
因为这个想法并不是说你对任何事情都无能为力。你可以做很多事情。只是你需要非常清楚界限，以及你到底能做什么和不能做什么，一旦你清楚了这一点，你的行动就会变得更加有效，因此你会感觉更好，从广义上讲，你会得到更好的结果。所以马可本人在可怕的瘟疫袭击他所在的世界时，也遵循了这个建议。马西莫，在那段时间里，罗马帝国发生了什么，马可又是如何应对的？是的，马可的统治因许多问题而变得非常困难。其中之一是安东尼瘟疫，这是古代最严重的瘟疫。它杀死了近五百万人，这很可能是由军团带回的麻疹引起的，
because The idea is not that you can't do anything about anything. You can do quite a bit It's just that you need to be very clear on the limits and what exactly it is that you can and cannot do and once you are clear on that your dimensions become much more efficacious and therefore you feel better and Broadly speaking you get better outcomes. So Marcus himself followed this advice when a terrible plague struck his part of the world. What happened during this time in the Roman Empire, Massimo, and how did Marcus respond to it? Yeah, Marcus' reign was made very difficult by a number of issues. One of them is the Antonine Plague, which was the worst plague to hit antiquity. It killed close to five million people, and it was probably caused by measles brought back by the legions that
他们在帝国东部作战。他还不得不处理自然灾害，台伯河的大洪水摧毁了罗马，一场大地震夷平了现代土耳其西部的士麦那。所以他有很多问题要处理。每次他都对自己说，好吧，这里什么取决于我，什么不取决于我？
were fighting on the east side of the empire. He also had to deal with natural disasters, a major flood of the Tiber that devastated Rome, a major earthquake that raised Smyrna in modern western Turkey. So he had a lot of issues to deal with. Every time he says to himself, okay, what here is up to me and what is not up to me?
例如，在瘟疫的情况下，帝国的资源已经被对帕提亚人的战争耗尽了。所以，你知道，尽管罗马帝国很富有，但显然是有极限的。所以马可认为取决于他的一件事是，实际上卖掉很多帝国国库和珠宝。所以他基本上进行了拍卖，在那里他
For instance, in the case of the plague, the resources of the empire were already depleted by the war against the Parthians. So, you know, even though the Roman empire was rich, there is a limit, obviously. And so what Marcus thought one of the things that was up to him was to actually sell a lot of the imperial treasury and jewels. So he essentially did auctions where he
卖掉了一堆他认为“我不需要这个”的东西。这并不能让我的生活变得更好，但它有潜力帮助救灾工作。所以这就是他所做的。但他并没有指望瘟疫会就这样消失。他说，我们首先不了解什么是瘟疫。我们不知道是什么导致了这件事。我们只能熬过去。我们只能尽我们所能去处理它，然后它会在某个时候自己消失。
sold out a bunch of stuff that he thought I don't need this. This is not making my life better but it has the potential to help with the relief effort. And so that's what he did. But he was not expecting the plague to just go away. He said, we don't understand what a plague is in the first place. We don't know what causes this thing. We just have to write it out. We just have to do our best in order to deal with it and then it will go away at some point
这是一种马可在他日记中写下类似“你在这里能做什么？你在哪里能有所作为？”的情况。同样重要的是，他不断对自己重复，在那些他无能为力的领域，没关系。他必须接受这一点。这不是你想为此失眠的事情，因为A，它没有帮助，B，如果你为此失眠，那么你在那些你实际上能做的事情上就会变得效率更低。
by itself. This was a situation where Marcus wrote in his journal something along the lines of what can you do here? Where can you make a difference? And just as importantly, he kept repeating to himself that in those areas where he couldn't do anything, it was okay. He had to accept that. This was not something that you want to lose your sleep over, because A, it doesn't help, and B, if you lose your sleep over it, then you're actually going to be less efficacious in the kind of things you actually can't do.
这改变了你对自己身体形象的看法吗，马西莫？改变了。这些天我被这个问题困扰得少多了。我专注于我能控制的事情。所以当我出去吃饭时，我尽量远离那些我知道对我不好东西，正如我和我妻子所说的，尽量减少损害。然后当我在家时，你知道，我们当然对我们吃的东西有更多的控制权。
Has this changed the way that you think about your own body image, Massimo? It has. I am far less bothered by the issue these days. I focus on what is under my control. So when I go out for dinner, I try to stay away from things that I know that are not good for me, minimize the damage as my wife and I call it. And then when I'm home, you know, we have more control of course over what we eat.
正如我所说，我定期去锻炼，我去看医生，你知道，就这样。但你知道，在疫情期间，例如，我再次被提醒爱比克泰德和马可是对的，因为有一天，我突然倒在地上，被送进了急诊室。我对我的身体完全没有控制力，什么都没有。
As I said, I go and exercise on a regular basis and I go to the doctor and you know, that's it. But you know, during the pandemic, for instance, I was reminded one more time that Epictetus and Marcus are right, because one day, I suddenly collapsed the floor and was brought to the emergency room. I had absolutely no control over my body, nothing.
结果是一个相当轻微的问题。那是椎间盘突出，我恢复得很快，你知道，感谢宙斯给了止痛药之类的东西。但那是一个即时的提醒，你知道，虽然现在你已经锻炼多年了，你吃得健康，所有这些事情，突然你早上醒来，你正要出门，你却因为对身体完全没有控制力的强烈感觉而倒在地上。好吧，爱比克泰德或马可此时会说什么？好吧，他们会说，好吧，你只是
Turns out to be a readily minor thing. It was a slipped disc and I recovered very quickly and you know thanked Zeus for painkillers and stuff like that. But that was an instant reminder that you know although now it's been years that you exercise, you eat healthy, all that sort of stuff, suddenly you wake up in the morning, you're about to go out and you collapse on the floor with the very intense feeling that you have no control over your body. Okay, what would Epictetus or Marcus have said at this point? Well, they would have said, okay, you just run
遇到了那些不取决于你的外部事物之一。你唯一能做的就是接受它，看看你能做些什么来恢复，来处理这种情况，等等。我了解到马可·奥勒留详细谈到了拥抱当下的紧迫性，因为我们谁都不知道我们还剩下多少这样的时刻。
into one of those externals that is not up to you. The only thing you can do is to accept it and see what you can do about it in order to recover, to handle the situation, et cetera. I understand that Marcus Aurelius talks at length about the urgency of embracing the present moment, since none of us ever know how many of those moments we have left.
谈谈这个想法，马西莫。没错，当我年轻的时候，像许多年轻人一样，你有点认为你是永生的。当然那不是真的，对吧？我的意思是，我最近查阅了我的精算统计数据，可以说，结果对于像我这个年龄和种族背景、住在纽约的人来说，
Talk about this idea, Massimo. That's right, when I was young, as a lot of young people, you kind of think that you're immortal. And that's of course not true, right? I mean, I have looked up my actuarial statistics, so to speak, sometime recently, and turns out that for somebody my age and my ethnic background living in New York,
有一个特定的预期寿命。我查了一下，说，哦，好吧，所以从统计学上讲，我还有几十年。但这只是从统计学上讲。当然，我今天可能会死。我可能会过马路，一辆车可能会撞到我，那就是终点。或者同样，我可能会感染致命疾病，我可能会死。所以一个人一生中随时都可能发生各种各样的事情，对吧？无论你是年轻、中年、晚年，等等等等。而斯多葛派所做的是，他们把这一点
there is a certain life expectancy. And I looked it up and said, oh, okay, so statistically speaking, I have a couple more decades. But that's only statistically speaking. Of course I could die today. I could cross the street and a car could hit me and that's the end of it. Or again, I could contract a lethal disease and I could die. So there is all sorts of stuff that can happen in any time in somebody's life, right? Whether you're young, middle-aged, late, et cetera, et cetera. And what the Stoics do is they bring that
带到了他们看待生活方式的最前沿。塞内卡，然后是马可，不断对自己说：表现得好像这是你生命的最后一天。或者如果你想更积极地表达，你早上起床，意识到你又多了一天。耶，庆祝那一天，因为你不知道你是否会有第二天，等等等等。现在这听起来可能有点令人沮丧，你知道，病态，所有这些东西，但事实上，他们在这里触及了一些根本性的东西。这个概念是，让我们的生活有意义的，恰恰是它是有限的这一事实。如果我们真的永远活着，如果你不得不做同样的事情
to the forefront of their way of looking at life. Seneca and then Marcus constantly say to themselves, act as if this was the last day of your life. Or if you want to put it more positively, you get up in the morning and you realize that you have one more day. Yay celebrate that day because you don't know if you're going to have a second one and so on and so forth. Now this may sound kind of depressing and you know morbid and all that sort of stuff but in fact they're getting at something fundamental here. The notion that what makes our life meaningful is precisely the fact that it's finite. If we actually live forever, if you if you got to do the same things
一遍又一遍，无限循环，什么都不会重要。你总有一个遥控器，你可以倒带并重做。所以它会失去意义。现实是，通过聚焦，通过提醒自己时间确实是有限的，不仅如此，而且你不知道你还剩下多少，那么你需要加倍努力，以一种有意义、快乐的方式度过你拥有的时间，你知道，这是你真正想度过一生的方式。这样想吧，所以你去，你在一次旅行中，在某个地方，
over and over and over ad infin and over, nothing will matter. You always have a remote controller you can rewind and redo it over. So it will lose meaning. The reality is, by focusing, by reminding yourself that time is in fact finite, and not only that, but that you don't know how much you have left then you need to redouble your efforts to spend the time that you have in a way that it's meaningful joyous you know it's the way you really want to spend your life think about it this way so you go you're on a on a trip somewhere
假设在西部国家公园附近的某个地方，你有一辆油表坏了的车。你不知道你还有多少油。你可以估计。你可以说，好吧，我三天前加满了油，所以也许在附近，但你不知道确定。现在，在那一点上，你需要对你要去哪里做出非常仔细的决定。
let's say in the national near the national parks out west, and you have a car where the gauge for the gas is broken. You don't know how much gas you have. You can estimate. You can say, well, I started out with a full tank three days ago, so perhaps it's around here, but you don't know for sure. Now, at that point, you need to make very careful decisions about where you're going.
你不能因为各种原因或根本没有原因就进行各种绕道，因为你可能会被困在荒郊野外。你可能无法做你真正想做的事情。马可·奥勒留提出的这一点，在一次“脑雾”发作让你住院时，对你来说变得非常深刻，因为这不仅关乎我们剩下的时间，还关乎我们剩下的美好时光。
You can't just take all sorts of detours for all sorts of reasons or for no reason at all, because you might get stuck in the middle of nowhere. You might not get to do what you actually want to do. This point that Marcus Aurelius is making was driven home for you, Massimo, when an episode of Brain Fog sent you to the hospital, because it's not just the amount of time we have left, but also the amount of good time that we have left.
是的，那是一次非常令人不安的经历，谢天谢地，现在没有再发生。基本上，我当时试图给我的学生写一封电子邮件，突然我意识到我的手指在敲击键盘，但我写的并不是我想写的内容。事实上，我不知道我在写什么。就像给我妻子打电话，我说，你知道，我想这里出了点问题。
Yeah, it was a very disturbing episode, which thankfully has now repeated itself. Basically, I was there trying to write an email to my students and all of a sudden I realized that my fingers were hitting the keyboard but I wasn't writing what I thought I was writing. I was in fact, I did not know what I was writing. It's like calling my wife and I said, you know, I think there's something wrong here.
是的，那是一次非常令人不安的经历，谢天谢地，现在它又发生了。基本上，当时我正试图给学生写一封电子邮件，突然我意识到我的手指虽然在敲击键盘，但我写出来的东西并不是我脑子里想的。事实上，我根本不知道自己在写什么。就像我给妻子打电话时说的那样，我觉得这里出问题了。
And we went immediately to the emergency room and they couldn't find anything wrong. Neither cardiologists. They couldn't find anything wrong. Neither cardiologists nor neurologists could find anything wrong. But nevertheless, it had happened. And so that was a wake-up call that there is also your mind that it's not up to you. So one of the things that the stoics insisted, as we said,
我们立刻去了急诊室，但他们什么也没查出来。心脏科医生也没查出来。心脏科医生和神经科医生都查不出任何问题。但尽管如此，事情确实发生了。所以那是一个警钟，提醒你还有你的思想，它并不完全受你控制。正如我们所说，斯多葛学派坚持的一点是，
was that your decision-making, your ability to make sound decisions, that's up to you. But even they understood that that's only provisional on the fact that your mind works more or less normally. At some point it might not, right? So take me back to the hospital when you went there with this thing of brain fog. What happened in the hospital and when and how
你的决策，你做出合理决策的能力，那是受你控制的。但即使是他们也明白，这仅仅是以你的大脑运作基本正常为前提的。在某种程度上，它可能无法正常运作，对吧？那么，带我回到你去医院处理脑雾的那次经历。医院里发生了什么，以及何时、如何
did you start to think about the Stoics and what was happening to you at that time? So they put me in an emergency room, which means it was somewhat crowded, you know, there was no privacy on it. But I did have my iPad and I did have a charger. And the first thing I did was to open meditations and discourses and the letters of Seneca and remind myself of, you know, what is it that these people are telling me that is so important to me, that is so meaningful to me? Right now I'm going through a crisis where I clearly have very little control.
你开始思考斯多葛学派以及当时发生在你身上的事情？他们把我安置在急诊室，这意味着那里有点拥挤，你知道，根本没有隐私可言。但我带了iPad和充电器。我做的第一件事就是打开《沉思录》、《谈话录》和塞内卡的信件，提醒自己，你知道，这些人告诉我的对我如此重要、如此有意义的事情到底是什么？此刻我正经历一场危机，显然我几乎无法控制局面。
There's not much I can do here, right? I'm in an emergency room at the mercy of both whatever is happening to my body and whatever the doctors and the nurses decide. There was the anxiety, of course, of not knowing what had happened. And maybe a doctor might show up either the same day or a week later and tell me, you know what?
我在这里无能为力，对吧？我身处急诊室，任由身体发生的情况以及医生和护士的决定摆布。当然，还有那种不知道发生了什么的焦虑。也许医生可能当天或一周后出现，然后告诉我，你知道吗？
You got a, I don't know, brain tumor or something like that, right? That was certainly a live possibility. But I decided to do two things about it. Number one, mostly cast that thought aside because, well, I don't know. And until I know, there is nothing I can do about it. And secondly, from time to time,
你得了，我不知道，脑瘤之类的东西，对吧？那当然是一种现实的可能性。但我决定对此做两件事。第一，尽量把那个想法抛诸脑后，因为，嗯，我不知道。在知道结果之前，我对此无能为力。第二，时不时地，
I again pick up my tablet and open my journal. And I started doing what the Stoics refer to as a premeditatio malorum, which means it's Latin for thinking about bad stuff happening in the future. The notion is to do it in the way in which Marcus was doing the meditations, analytically, detaching yourself,
我再次拿起平板电脑，打开我的日记。我开始做斯多葛学派所说的“预演不幸”（premeditatio malorum），也就是拉丁语中思考未来可能发生的坏事。其理念是以马可·奥勒留写《沉思录》的方式去做，即分析性地、抽离地，
writing to yourself in the second person. And so I wrote to myself in the second person, okay, so there is a chance that there is something wrong here either with your heart or your brain. So what are you going to do about it? How are you going to deal with this situation? If the situation, assuming that the situation is one of the worst case scenarios, are you ready to handle it?
用第二人称对自己写作。所以我用第二人称对自己写道，好吧，你的心脏或大脑确实有可能出了问题。那你打算怎么办？你打算如何处理这种情况？如果情况，假设情况是最坏的情况之一，你准备好应对了吗？
And what are you going to do in terms of handling it? Well, one of the first things you're going to do is to figure out as much as possible what in fact it is, so listen to your doctors and what they're saying, then get a good reasonable estimate of what might happen in the near future, how long that future might be, and then you redirect, you reorganize your life accordingly. You make the best use possible of that time. issues possible of that time. When we come back, more ideas about what it means to live a good life. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Do you have follow-up questions about stoicism?
你打算如何处理它？嗯，你要做的第一件事就是尽可能弄清楚它到底是什么，所以听听医生的建议，了解他们怎么说，然后对不久的将来可能发生的事情、未来可能持续多久，得出一个合理且客观的评估，然后你相应地调整、重组你的生活。你要尽可能充分利用那段时间。充分利用那段时间。稍后回来，我们将探讨更多关于过上美好生活的想法。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你对斯多葛学派有后续问题吗？
Have you had moments in your life when you were able to muster your inner stoic and moments you could not? If you'd be comfortable sharing your thoughts, comments, and questions with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, stoicism. The Roman leader Marcus Aurelius lived through turbulent times. Still, he found ways to attend to his inner world. Indeed, he argued that it is only by attending to our inner worlds that our outer worlds can begin to make sense.
你的生活中是否有过能够鼓起内在斯多葛精神的时刻，以及无法做到的时刻？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享你的想法、评论和问题，请在手机上录制一段语音备忘录，并发送电子邮件至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请注明“斯多葛学派”。罗马领袖马可·奥勒留生活在动荡的时代。尽管如此，他还是找到了关注内心世界的方法。事实上，他认为只有通过关注我们的内心世界，我们的外部世界才能开始变得有意义。
Massimo Piliucci is a philosopher at the City College of New York. He is the author of How to be a Stoic, Massimo Piliucci is a philosopher at the City College of New York. He is the author of How to be a Stoic, Using Ancient Philosophy to Live a Modern Life. He is also the co-author, with Gregory Lopez and Meredith Alexander-Kunz, of Beyond Stoicism, a guide to the good life with Stoics, Skeptics, Epicureans, and other ancient philosophers. Massimo, before you started studying stoicism, you often found your emotions spinning out of control. I understand a pet peeve of yours
马西莫·皮利乌奇是纽约市立学院的哲学家。他是《如何成为一名斯多葛主义者：用古老的哲学过现代生活》的作者。他还是与格雷戈里·洛佩兹和梅雷迪思·亚历山大-昆兹合著的《超越斯多葛学派：与斯多葛主义者、怀疑论者、伊壁鸠鲁学派及其他古代哲学家一起过美好生活的指南》的合著者。马西莫，在你开始研究斯多葛学派之前，你经常发现自己的情绪失控。我了解到你的一件心头大患
was the issue of people pulling out their phones in the middle of a movie or a show? Yes, you have no idea how many times I got upset about that. Because to me, this was inconceivable. I would say to myself, how is this guy possibly not aware of the fact that in the middle of the movie he's raising his phone and now everybody behind him is looking at his phone instead
是人们在电影或演出中拿出手机的问题？是的，你无法想象我为此感到多么沮丧。因为对我来说，这是不可思议的。我会对自己说，这家伙怎么可能没意识到，在电影放映过程中他举起手机，现在他身后所有人都盯着他的手机，而不是
of the movie? How rude! How could you be so inconsiderate about that sort of stuff? And that would of course ruin my whole experience at the movies because what are you gonna do about it? I mean, sometimes I did go and confront the person, usually fairly nicely. And I got all sorts of responses from the occasional polite, oh, I'm sorry, I didn't realize it,
电影？太粗鲁了！你怎么能对那种事情如此不体贴？这当然会毁掉我整个观影体验，因为你对此能做什么呢？我的意思是，有时我确实会去和那个人对质，通常态度还算客气。我得到了各种各样的回应，偶尔有礼貌的“哦，对不起，我没意识到”，
to some funny people telling me off and reacting in a very angry fashion. He said, I have a right to do whatever they want with my face. I was like, no, you don't, you're not at home. You're not in your home He said, I have a right to do whatever they want with my friends. Like, no, you don't, you're not at home. You're not in your home. You don't have a right. So sometimes those things will escalate,
到一些滑稽的人反驳我，反应非常愤怒。他说，我有权对我的手机做任何我想做的事。我说，不，你没有，你不在家里。你不在你的家里。他说，我有权对我的手机做任何我想做的事。我说，不，你没有，你不在家里。你不在你的家里。你没有权利。所以有时这些事情会升级，
not to the point of physical violence, but certainly of raised voices or storming off and calling the manager of the movie theater, who usually is impossible to find for whatever reason. And so there was a number of times when this happened. And of course, this is a minor thing, right? I mean, you can reasonably argue, look, man, there's a lot more important things to get upset about,
虽然没有达到肢体冲突的地步，但肯定会提高嗓门，或者愤然离去，并叫来电影院经理，而无论出于什么原因，经理通常都找不到。所以这种情况发生过很多次。当然，这是一件小事，对吧？我的意思是，你可以合理地争辩说，看，伙计，还有很多更重要的事情值得生气，
but it was not just the fact in itself. It was the inconceivability that somebody would be so clueless or so inconsiderate to actually do that kind of thing. Or someone playing music loudly on the subway was another. Oh yeah, you know, there are some people apparently who have not realized that we invented these wonderful things called earbuds.
但这不仅仅是事实本身。而是有人竟然如此无知或如此不体贴，以至于真的会做那种事，这简直不可思议。或者有人在地铁上大声播放音乐是另一回事。哦，是的，你知道，显然有些人还没有意识到我们发明了这些美妙的东西，叫做耳塞。
You can put them in your ear and not bother anybody. And I thought often, you know, when I used to get upset about the subway experience, I thought maybe one of these days I just have to come into the subway with a very large boombox. And as soon as I hear somebody doing that, turn my own at the highest possible volume to show him what it's going to happen.
你可以把它们塞进耳朵里，而不打扰任何人。我经常想，你知道，当我过去因为地铁上的经历而感到沮丧时，我想也许有一天我必须带着一个非常大的音箱进入地铁。一旦我听到有人那样做，我就以尽可能大的音量打开我自己的音箱，向他展示会发生什么。
You know, it's as a teaching lesson, not as, not as a, in a vindictive way, but as a teaching lesson, you see what would happen if everybody were doing that. I never actually did it, but it's been in the back of my mind for a while. Marcus says, why do you expect people to be different from what they are? That's insane.
你知道，这是一种教学课程，不是，不是以一种报复的方式，而是作为一种教学课程，你看如果每个人都那样做会发生什么。我从来没有真正做过，但它在我的脑海里已经有一段时间了。马可说，你为什么期望人们与他们本来的样子不同？那太疯狂了。
That's just crazy. You know that people are in a certain way. There is a place in the meditation where it says, you know, remember when you get up in the morning and you get out of the door, remind yourself that you will encounter all sorts of inconsiderate people who will do all sorts of things that you don't like. This is just a fact of life. Now you can deal with the situation. In some cases you can correct them. I don't want to give the impression that, you know, that stoicism is about just laid back and taking it, right?
那简直是疯了。你知道人们就是那样。在《沉思录》中有一个地方说，你知道，记住当你早上起床出门时，提醒自己你会遇到各种各样不体贴的人，他们会做各种你不喜欢的事情。这只是生活的一个事实。现在你可以处理这种情况。在某些情况下，你可以纠正他们。我不想给人留下一种印象，你知道，斯多葛学派只是随遇而安，接受一切，对吧？
This is called the danger of doormatism, of turning yourself into a doormat so that everybody walks all over you. That's not the point. Marcus says explicitly, there are two things you can do when somebody's behaving in a way that you disapprove of. One is to teach them, to explain to them, you know, look, this is problematic because.
这被称为“门垫主义”的危险，把自己变成一块门垫，让每个人都从你身上踩过去。那不是重点。马可明确表示，当有人以你不赞同的方式行事时，你可以做两件事。一是教导他们，向他们解释，你知道，看，这有问题，因为……
And then failing that, you can bear with them. You can use your ability to, your patience, your ability to withstand things as a result. Because what else are you going to do? Right? Those are pretty much your two options. So you just have to... It's not that the two are incompatible. Of course, you're going to argue and you're going to try to do things in order to improve the situation.
如果做不到，你可以忍受他们。你可以利用你的能力，你的耐心，你承受事情的能力作为结果。因为你还能做什么呢？对吧？这基本上是你的两个选择。所以你只需要……并不是说两者是不相容的。当然，你会争论，你会尝试做一些事情来改善情况。
But if that fails, then you have to accept that, okay, this time reality didn't go my way. Too bad. So he says in one of the passages, the cucumber is bitter, toss it away. There are briars in the path, turn aside. That is enough. You don't need to add, why are such things found in the world. For you would
但如果失败了，那么你必须接受，好吧，这次现实没有如我所愿。真糟糕。所以他在其中一段中说，黄瓜是苦的，把它扔掉。路上有荆棘，绕道而行。这就足够了。你不需要补充说，为什么世界上会有这样的东西。因为你会
be a laughing stock to any student of nature, just as you would be laughed at by a carpenter and a cobbler if you took them to task, because in their shops are seen sawdust and pairings from what they are making. Yep, exactly. So he's saying, look, there are certain things that inevitably have certain consequences. If you are in the business of working wood, well, there's going to be sawdust. So you cannot complain, you cannot reasonably complain, you could complain, but it's not reasonable to complain about all the dust in the shop, because that's an inevitable byproduct of the fact that you're working wood. And so similarly, to complain about the fact that some people behave irrational, inconsiderately,
成为任何自然研究者的笑柄，就像如果你去指责木匠和鞋匠，他们也会嘲笑你，因为在他们的店里可以看到锯末和他们制作东西时留下的碎屑。是的，完全正确。所以他在说，看，有些事情不可避免地会有某些后果。如果你从事木工行业，嗯，肯定会有锯末。所以你不能抱怨，你不能合理地抱怨，你可以抱怨，但抱怨店里的灰尘是不合理的，因为那是你从事木工工作的必然副产品。同样地，抱怨有些人表现得不理性、不体贴，
or rudely, or whatever it is, under certain circumstances, it's like, what, have you never met human beings before? Don't you know that this is the way it works? Which incidentally doesn't mean that people always do that, right? Or that they're incorrigible. So that's why Marcus says, you go and teach them, talk to them, right? If something bothers you, instead of getting upset and complaining about the world, just do something about it, right? In another bit of the Meditations, he also says,
或者粗鲁，或者无论是什么，在某些情况下，就像是，什么，你以前没见过人类吗？你不知道事情就是这样运作的吗？顺便说一句，这并不意味着人们总是那样做，对吧？或者他们是不可救药的。这就是为什么马可说，你去教导他们，和他们谈谈，对吧？如果有什么事情困扰你，与其生气和抱怨世界，不如做点什么，对吧？在《沉思录》的另一部分，他还说，
you know, remember that it's really impious to not to do, not to act on behalf, you know, justly and try to correct injustice. So this isn't about not doing anything. It's about a more realistic approach to reality. And a less self-centered approach. Because in a sense, right, if you complain about the cucumbers and the briars and all that sort of stuff, this is a very self-centered view of reality. You want the world to always accommodate to your wishes and to your preferences, but that's insane. That's an extreme degree of narcissism, which is not healthy, right?
你知道，记住，不采取行动，不代表正义行事并试图纠正不公正，这真的是不虔诚的。所以这并不是关于什么都不做。这是关于一种更现实的现实方法。以及一种不那么以自我为中心的方法。因为在某种意义上，对吧，如果你抱怨黄瓜、荆棘和所有这些东西，这是一种非常以自我为中心的现实观。你希望世界总是迎合你的愿望和偏好，但这太疯狂了。这是一种极端的自恋，是不健康的，对吧？
["The Last Supper"] So you recently had an occasion to practice what Marcus Aurelius preached in the face of an adverse event. Tell me the story of what happened when you were headed to a subway train in Rome. Oh, yeah. So the situation was I was supposed to meet my brother in Rome. Rome is the city where I grew up, so I'm very comfortable navigating everything, including the subway system.
["最后的晚餐"] 所以你最近有机会在面对不利事件时实践马可·奥勒留的教导。讲讲当你前往罗马地铁列车时发生的事情。哦，是的。情况是我本来要和我的兄弟在罗马见面。罗马是我长大的城市，所以我对导航一切都很自在，包括地铁系统。
So I got on the subway and suddenly I feel this guy right in front of me near the entrance, it's kind of pushing back very, very hard as if the subway were overcrowded. And it was like, but it wasn't overcrowded. I mean, there was a little bit of people, but not enough to justify that kind of behavior. So the first thought was, what is this guy doing?
所以我上了地铁，突然我感觉到我面前入口处的那个人，推得非常非常用力，好像地铁很拥挤一样。就像是，但它并不拥挤。我的意思是，人有点多，但不足以证明那种行为。所以第一个想法是，这家伙在干什么？
And before I realized what in fact he was doing, it had already happened. This guy had a friend, an associate behind me, who while I was distracted with the physical pressure of the other one pushing back on me, he just picked my pocket. So the wallet was gone. And by the time I realized that's what was going to happen, it took a fraction of a second, but it was too late. Already the two were out of the subway, the doors were closing, and that's it. I was all of a sudden without a wallet.
在我意识到他实际上在做什么之前，事情已经发生了。这家伙有一个同伙，一个在我身后的同伙，当我的注意力被另一个人推我的物理压力分散时，他直接偷了我的钱包。所以钱包不见了。当我意识到会发生什么时，只花了一秒钟的时间，但已经太晚了。那两个人已经出了地铁，车门正在关闭，就是这样。我突然之间没有了钱包。
Now, if this happened years ago, I would have been really upset. I would have been angry, both for myself for being so stupid. It's like, you know, I grew up in this city. I know that these things happened. I was in a particularly touristy area of Rome, so of course these things happen. You know, again, briars and cucumbers, right? Why would you expect that not to happen? I was angry and myself, I was angry at those two people. It's like how dare they violate my person and my property and so on and so forth. So it would have been a normal reaction. Be upset, to be angry, to be dejected afterwards once you realize what the consequences that action etc etc. And to my surprise instead the first thing that came up to my mind was what here is up to you and what is not up to you?
现在，如果这发生在几年前，我会非常沮丧。我会很生气，既为自己如此愚蠢而生气。就像，你知道，我在这座城市长大。我知道这些事情发生过。我当时在罗马一个特别游客众多的地区，所以当然这些事情会发生。你知道，再次强调，荆棘和黄瓜，对吧？你为什么会期望那不会发生？我对自己很生气，我对那两个人很生气。就像他们怎么敢侵犯我的人身和财产等等。所以这会是一个正常的反应。事后意识到后果时感到沮丧、愤怒、失望等等。令我惊讶的是，相反，我脑海中浮现的第一件事是：这里什么是受你控制的，什么是不受你控制的？
Ah thank you Marcus. So here's the thing I sat down I put out my phone fortunately they did not get my smartphone and Unfortunately, the Rome subway has Wi-Fi everywhere, including in tunnels. So the phone was working perfectly. So what did I do? I thought about it for a second. It's like, okay, let's make a list here. I immediately contacted via app the credit card companies, blocked the credit cards. I contacted the DMV and immediately asked for a replacement driver license, which by the way they sent immediately, like a few days later it was in the mail, and they immediately allowed me to download a PDF, the function as a temporary driver license. I'm
啊，谢谢你，马可。所以事情是这样的，我坐下来，拿出我的手机，幸运的是他们没有拿走我的智能手机，而且不幸的是，罗马地铁到处都有Wi-Fi，包括隧道里。所以手机工作得非常完美。所以我做了什么？我思考了一秒钟。就像，好吧，列个清单。我立即通过应用程序联系了信用卡公司，冻结了信用卡。我联系了车管所（DMV），立即申请补办驾照，顺便说一下，他们立即寄出了，几天后就寄到了，而且他们立即允许我下载一份PDF文件，作为临时驾照使用。我
saying this because Americans often complain so much about the DMV. It's usually the quintessential example of everything that is wrong with bureaucracy. I don't know what they're talking about. It was very good. So I did that. Then I thought, okay, how much cash did I have there? Less than $100. Okay. Fortunately for me, I can absorb that kind of loss without really much of an impact. Is there anything else that is left to be done? No. So I sat down, I switched to a different app, I started reading a book, and a few stops
之所以这么说，是因为美国人经常抱怨车管所。它通常是官僚主义一切错误的典型例子。我不知道他们在说什么。它非常好。所以我做了这些。然后我想，好吧，我那里有多少现金？不到100美元。好吧。幸运的是，我可以承受那种损失，而不会产生太大的影响。还有什么需要做的吗？没有。所以我坐下来，切换到另一个应用程序，开始看书，几站
later I got off and I met my brother. Now I told him what happened and my brother of course said, well, I I don't see you upset what what what's going on here you don't you don't seem to be particularly you know bothered by this thing and I said would it help I solved what I could I took care immediately of what I could and I and I told him the guess what now dinner is on you because I have no money what now dinner is on you because I have no money. It worked. The philosopher Jean-Paul Sartre once said, hell is other people. In our companion story to this episode, available exclusively to subscribers to Hidden Brain Plus, we explore ideas from Marcus Aurelius and the Stoics about how we can best manage
后我下车见到了我的兄弟。现在我告诉他发生了什么，我的兄弟当然说，嗯，我没看到你生气，怎么回事，你看起来并没有特别被这件事困扰，我说这会有帮助吗？我解决了力所能及的事情，我立即处理了我能处理的事情，我告诉他，猜猜怎么着，现在晚餐你请客，因为我没钱了。现在晚餐你请客，因为我没钱了。它奏效了。哲学家让-保罗·萨特曾经说过，他人即地狱。在我们本集的配套故事中，仅供《隐藏的大脑 Plus》订阅者使用，我们探讨了马可·奥勒留和斯多葛学派关于我们如何最好地管理
our relationships with others. It's titled U2.0, How to Survive Other People. If you're not yet a subscriber, please visit support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, you can go to apple.co slash hiddenbrain. You can get a free seven day trial in both places. You'll instantly have access
我们与他人的关系的想法。标题是《U2.0，如何从他人手中幸存》。如果你还不是订阅者，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，可以访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。你可以在这两个地方获得七天的免费试用。你将立即获得访问权限
to all our subscriber-only content. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. Massimo Piliucci is a philosopher at the City College of New York. He is the author of How to be a Stoic, Using Ancient Philosophy to Live a Modern Life. He's also the co-author, with Gregory Lopez and Meredith Alexander-Kunz, of Beyond Stoicism, A Guide to the Good Life, with Stoics, Skeptics, Epicureans, and other ancient philosophers. Massimo, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was a pleasure.
我们所有的订阅者专属内容。再说一遍，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.co/hiddenbrain。马西莫·皮利乌奇是纽约市立学院的哲学家。他是《如何成为一名斯多葛主义者：用古老的哲学过现代生活》的作者。他还是与格雷戈里·洛佩兹和梅雷迪思·亚历山大-昆兹合著的《超越斯多葛学派：与斯多葛主义者、怀疑论者、伊壁鸠鲁学派及其他古代哲学家一起过美好生活的指南》的合著者。马西莫，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。这是我的荣幸。
Thanks for having me. at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line stoicism. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
谢谢邀请。发送至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请注明“斯多葛学派”。再次重申，电子邮件地址是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。
Our unsung hero this week is Logan Snyder of Haz Optimization, a firm that does web design, development, and maintenance, as well as digital marketing. We recently started working with Logan and the Haz Optimization team, and they've made the work of maintaining hiddenbrain.org so much easier. If you need help running your website check them out at hasopt.com that's hasopt.com. Thank you Logan. If you're enjoying the episodes in our U2.0 series, please share them with two or three
我们本周的无名英雄是 Haz Optimization 的洛根·斯奈德，这是一家从事网页设计、开发和维护以及数字营销的公司。我们最近开始与洛根和 Haz Optimization 团队合作，他们让维护 hiddenbrain.org 的工作变得轻松多了。如果你需要帮助运营你的网站，请访问 hasopt.com，即 hasopt.com。谢谢你，洛根。如果你喜欢我们 U2.0 系列的剧集，请与你生活中的两三个人分享。
people in your life. You can find all the episodes in the series on your preferred podcast platform or at hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在你喜欢的播客平台或 hiddenbrain.org 上找到该系列的所有剧集。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。